تبادل التارسي واوكرانيا للتهابات
بالمسؤوليه عن استمرار الحرب بينهما
واجهاض امكانيه التفاوض لايقافيه بينما
يستمر القتال بين قوات البلدين قال الرئيس
الروسي الذيب بوتين ان روسيا جاهزه
للتفاوض مؤكد ان خصومها يسعون لتفكيكها في
اشاره الاستقطاب الدوليه يشهد حركا يدفع
بيجين لتعميق على قاتها لاستراتيجيه بمصر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولذا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مساره
التي تصدر عن موسكو بشان عدم رغبه كل طرف
في المفاوضات وفي اي سياق الميداني
وسياسيين اتت ومن الاعوام التي تعطل
الدخول في مفاوضات لانهاء الحرب الدائره
في اوكرانيا وكيف تنعكسه الاستقطابات
الدوريه على مسار الحربي في ضوء اعلان
بيجين عن توجهها نحو علاقه نستراتيجيه
اكثر عمقا مع موسكو بعد سماح واشنطن
بتقديم الدعم العسكري الفوري
وما هي فرص تخفيض حده التوتر وايجاد مخرجا
من الازمه الراهنه في ضوء هذه التعقيدات
المتداخله
[موسيقى]
قليل من الحراك الرامي لايقاف الحرب كثير
من التصعيد الميداني والاستقطاب الدولي
بين قوى الكبرى على علاقه من قريب وبعيد
بالحرب الدائره رحاها في اوكرانيا دك ما
استقر عليه المشهد الى حد الان وان لم
يمنع ذلك الرئيس الروسي من تجديد استعداده
للتفاوض وهو اول العارفين كما نظيره
الاوكراني ان الامر يتعلق بهوه صحيفه تفصل
نظره الطرفين لمقدمات الحل المنشود فضلا
عن استقطاب دوليا حول الحرب وملفات اخرى
تدفع الصين هذه الايام للتوجه اكثر نحوهما
تصفه بالعلاقات الاستراتيجيه مع موسكو في
ظل هذا وذاك
تتتالى تصريحاته على اعلى المستويات دون
بسيط
لضوء ان يلوحه من اخر نفق هذا الاحترام
المستمر نتبعه اول ما قاله الرئيس الروسي
دائما الى حال كل القضايا الاشكاليه سلميه
عبر التفاوض للاسف الجانب الاخر كان لديه
نهج مختلف اذ بدا باتخاذ خطوات صارمه
وتنفيذ عمليات العسكريه فاضطررنا لحمايه
الناس الذين يقطنون تلك الاراضي لسنا نحن
من قام بتنفيذ الانقلاب في اوكرانيا
وجوهرو كل ما يحدث هو سياسه خصوم من الجيو
سياسيه التي تهدف الى تفكيك روسيا عبر
التاريخ هدفنا توحيد الشعب الروسي نعمل في
الاتجاه الصحيح لنحميه مصالحنا ومصالحنا
ولا يوجد لدينا خيار اخر
في الجهه المقابله قال ميخائيل بودلاك
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ان روسيا لا تريد
التفاوض وهي تحاول تجنب المسؤوليه وتواصل
قتل المدنيين واضاف المسؤول الاوكراني
والنبوتين يحتاج الى عوده الى الواقع في
هذه الاثناء دعا الرئيس الامريكي شعبه الى
عدم الخضوع للحرب المستمره منذ 10 اشهر
وحتى الاوكرانيين على الاصرار والمثابره
ميدانيه تتواصل المعارك هو عمليات القصف
المتبادل على طول الجبهه الاوكرانيه
وتزامرت مع ذويه صفارات الانذار في عدد من
المدن الاوكرانيه تحسبا من غارات جويه
روسيه وفي حينعلنا الجانب الاوكراني عند
القوات الروسيه جددت خاصه لمقاطعه
وميكو لايف وان الجيش الاوكرانيه في
المقابل وجه ضربته للقوات الروسيه وامسك
بخطوط القتال ولا سيما في المناطق الريفيه
بينما يحدث ذلك ركز الجانب الروسي على
نتائج الخسائر المدنيه التي تم تسجيلها
جراء قصف الاوكرانيا على المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها في لوجان سقوطه صواريخ من
تراث هاي مارس الامريكيه الروسيه
كل هذه التطورات المدنيه يحيط بها مناخ
دولي عنوانه العريض هو الاستقطاب الحاد ما
يجعل القوه الكبرى ابعد منذ قبل عن
التوافق حول حلول سلميه فها هي الصين تتجه
اكثر فاكثر صوبه تعميقه علاقاتها
الاستراتيجيه بموسكو في ظل تصاعد التوتري
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين
على خلفيه تايوان وزير الخارجيه الصينيه
وان جي قال ان علاقته بلده مع واشنطن
تواجهه تحديات خطيره بسبب استمرار ما تم
عناد واشنطن في رؤيه بيجين كم منافسين
رئيسي
الوزير الصينيه اكد علاقه الصين مع روسيا
قويه وتقوم على التعاون وعدم المواجهه
وعدم استهداف طرف ثالث مبديا رفض بلده
الشديد لسياسه الاداره الامريكيه تجاهها
الصين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
موسكو السفير اندريه باكلانو نيبو رئيسي
جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس ومعنى بالواشنطن
السفير ويليام كارتني مساعد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق كلينتون لشؤون روسيا
واوكرانيا وابدا بضيفي من موسكو
حديث التفاوض يعني ياتي في سياقات كثيره
هذه المره السياق همم انه همم سياق
التلاوه هل هذا نابع من
قناه على هذا الطرفين بهذا المفاوضات غير
ممكنه الان ام نابع من امل بان همم ذكر
التفاوض اكثر من مره قد يوحي بانه هنالك
تفوضا سيجري في وقت
اكشن
اليوم رئيسنا اكد على استعدادنا مبدئيا في
من اجل التحدث لكن هنالك مشكلتان اولهما
المفاوضات
مشكله الثانيه
لعدد من السنوات بدانا بالمحادثات وتبين
لنا انها كانت هذه
محاوله لخداعي روسيا وكان هنالك ايضا ان
محاولات من المستشاره السابقه لالمانيا هي
اعترفت حقا ان الاتفاقيات اتفاق
كان فقط محاوله لخداع روسيا ولم يكون
هنالك رغبه
بتلبيه شروطي ذلك الاتفاق اذن نحن مستعدون
لكننا حذرون في نفس الوقت
السفير ويليام كوتني من وجهه النظر
الامريكيه ما الذي يعقوق
الانخراط في التفاوض الان ما هي عقده
المنشار
بان الكريم لانه جاد بشان المفاوضات ان
كان الكلام
نتوقع
بعض المؤشرات في الميدان على سبيل المثال
لا توقف روسيا استهدافها وقصفها للمنشات
المدنيه كما فعلت هذا اليوم او نرى
تخفيضا في حشدي وتحدي وتعبئته القوات في
ساحات المعارك لكن مره اخرى
عسكريه توحي بان روسيا صادقه وان خطابها
بشان تفكيرها همم
الانسحاب من اوكرانيا
وبالتالي يعني كيف يعني عاده ان المفاوضات
تحصل حينما تح الحرب ما يكفي
للتفاوض من وجهه النظر الامريكيه سيد
قاتلي هذه الحرب الان حققت ما يكفي مروجه
النظر الامريكيه والاوكرانيه
همم
تحدث عندما
ينهك الطرفان ولا يرى اي مكتسبات او اهداف
تتحقق مع مواصله القتال وهذا ما حدث في
منتصف التسعينات خلال الحرب البوسنيه
وخصمه
في الميدان بعد دفعهما الى الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوض ولكن ليس هناك اي مباشره
حقيقيه بعد من قبل تشيء بان موسكو
اوكرانيا وقد وصلت الى حد الاستنزاف
ما زالتها ماضيه ثاني في هذه الحرب ومن
الناحيه العسكريه فان اوكراني ربما لديها
اليد العليا في هذا النزاع العسكري الى
الان
عاده همم تبدا المفاوضات حينما يتعب الناس
من الحرب ضيفنا الى الولايات المتحده يقول
لم نتعب بعد سيد اندريه بكلانو ما معنى
همم
التكرار الحديث القدر الروس عن المفاوضات
وايه رمي الكره في الملعب الخصم لانه
دائما الحديث الروسي عن المفاوضات لا ياتي
بخطه يعني يتحدث عن مستعدون للتفاوض كما
تفضلت لكن لا توجد خط عليا اساس يتم
التفاوض امان هذا مجرد دار للرامات في
العيون لانه الطرفين لم يتعبه كما قال
ضيفنا بالواجب
في حقيقه الامر عندما نتحدث عن المفاوضات
هي علينا ان
نفهم بجديه
الواقع الحالي والواقع 4 رجل
طبيعي
اقليميه ويتعلق بالاراضي
السلطات الاوكرانيه تطالب بعوده هذه
الاراضي الى تحت سيطرتها بالنسبه لروسيا
هذه قضيه حساسه لانها كان هناك تصويت في
البرلمانات من اجل عوده هذه الاجزاء
والاقاليم التي كانت جزء من روسيا في
العهد السوفيتي السابق بالتالي
كيف بامكاننا ان نعالج هذا الجانب المتعلق
بالاراضي الجانب الاخر قد يكون اسهل بنسبه
لنا في الجوانب تكون اسهل في التعامل معها
التصريحات تاتي في ظل
يعني حاله استقطاب دوله موجوده في مختلفه
انحاء العالم
الى اي درجه هذا هذه المواجهه المكتومه
وتظهر العالم بين الف ليله والاخرى بين
الولايات المتحده والصين تؤثر ايضا على ما
يجري في اوكرانيا هل ما يجري في اوكرانيا
يمكن ان يكون بالمعزل عن الجو والسياق
الدوري العام
وضع
تشاينيون في عام 2014
والحال هكذا همم الى اي مدى همم تنظر
روسيا الى تصريحات الصينيين بان الصين
مستعده لبناء علاقات اكثر عمقا مع موسكو
الى اي مدى تاخذ موسكو ذلك على محمل الجد
وكيف يمكن ان تكون اكثر عمقا اذا كانت
الصين لم تخطوا خطوات اا تريدها موسكو
بسبب العقوبات الامريكيه على روسيا
في حقيقه الامر كما تعرفون
فان ما سالت اوكرانيا هي المساله
الاكثر الحاحا حاليا لكنها ليست
الاسس التي تعتمد عليها علاقتنا مع الصين
بكل لكل مع كل الاحترام للازمه في
اوكرانيا لدينا فرص اكبر من اجلي
رينو عميق العلاقات مع اصيل لدينا علاقات
تجاريه واقتصاديه ولدينا ايضا مواقف
متشابهه تجاه
الممارسات الغربيه والامريكيه والعقوبات
بالتالي هنالك الكثير من الجوانب التي
توحدوناها مع الصين الجانب الاوكراني او
الازمه الاوكرانيه هو امر دقيق وحساس
للغايه
نعرفهم لا يدعموننا بشكل كامل لكنهم
يتفهمون وجهه نظرنا بالتالي فان موقف
التفاهم هذا مهم وهذا من الواضح بالنسبه
لنا هو امر كافر
عمقا على المستوى الاستراتيجي هل تعتقد
انه يمكن ان تؤثر باي حال من الاحوال على
حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
ناوي
على الحياه ولا تساعد روسيا في حربها
الصين لا تصلحه روسيا على سبيل المثال
ولذلك
سيدنا
جانب الروسيه
الروسيه ضعيفه للغايه وهم لا يحصلون على
العتاد ولا الاسلحه الجيده
وراينا عدد من المؤسسات الامنيه الروسيه
على قواتها في اوكرانيا تتلاشى وتضبح محل
والكريمه ايضا ي ومشاكل بدوره فالرئيس
مواطن على سبيل المثال لما همم
يقدم خطابه امام الجمعيه الفيدراليه ولا
حتى همم يقوم بالقاء خطابه او مؤتمرها
الصحفي المعتاد كلها
ولماذا في رايك السفير اندريه بكلانو هل
هذا ماذا يعكس تحديدا هل يعكس عدم همم رضا
عن الاداء عدم ثقه في همم ما يمكن ان
يقوله للناس مثل هذا المؤتمرات هذه نقطه
كانت لا في فعلا فيما يتعلق على اقل من
المؤتمر الصحفي الثانوي
بامكان دقيق بشكل اكبر في سؤال
في هذه الحرب
السيطره على جنوده في اوكرانيا وانه لم
يعد يقيم
مؤتمرات كما كان يفعل من قبل ويتحدث بنفس
الدرجه كما كان يفعل من قبل واخرها ما حدث
في المؤتمر الصحفي السنوي الذي لم ااه لم
لم يفعله هذه مره
حقيقه الامر انا لدي انطباع مختلف عن ما
كان يجري
كما تعرفون انا كنت اعيش في اوكرانيا
لسنوات عديده بالتالي لدي معلومات اضافيه
عما يحدث على الارض وايضا لدي الانطباع
اما يقوله
رئيسنا يبدولي وكانه
لدينا بعض الانتكاسات في التعامل مع
اصلاحات الجيش نحن لم ننتهي من
كان ضروري لكننا مستمرون في هذه الاصلاحات
والاصلاحات من اجل تهيئه الجيش والامر
سيتطلب بعض الوقت اعتقد ان هذا الامر قد
يتطلب سنه او سنتين قبل ان يصل جيشنا الى
افضل
كثير من الوقت اذا لم يحدث ذلك لانه كانت
هذه هي توقعات قبل الحرب كانت التوقعات
قبل الحرب والرئيس فوت الاعتراف نفسه بان
الحرب لم تسر كما كان يتوقع هو
همم اذا صارت الامور على عكس ما يتوقع ما
هي النقطه التي سيقول عندها ان هذه الحرب
حرب فاشله وينبغي ان تقف وينبغي ان يتفاوض
الان على الخروج
همم
لما نضع
لهذه العمليه لم يتم ذكر اذا ما كانت هذه
العمليه
وقتا طويلا ام قصيرا بالتالي هذا امر
طبيعي لا يمكننا ان نخلق المعجزات بعد
ثمان سنوات
الجيش الاوكراني مثلا لهذه المعارك
بالتالي نحتاج الى بعض الوقت من اجل
في الاجراءات الا ضروريه وتحركات ضروريه
من اجل تحقيق النصر لكننا متاكدونا ان هذا
النصر سيتحقق هذا امر محكوم ليس لدينا اي
شكل
ايضا ما هي النقطه التي يمكن فيها واشنطن
ان تنصح الاخ همم وانا اقول تنصح بدل تضغط
وهي تستطيع ان تضغط طبعا على الاوكرانيين
لتقول لهم هذا يكفي لنوقف هذه الحرب
الولايات المتحده قالت بانها ستواصل دعم
اوكرانيا
طالما كانت قادره على الدفاع عن بلدها
وقادر على الدفاع عن اراضيها واشنطن
والدول الغربيه لن تضغط على الرئيس
اليانسكي ولا على الاوكرانيين
لينخرطوا في مفاوضات للتواصل الاتفاق سلام
في الوقت الذي تصيروا فيه روسيا على مزيد
من العراق الاوكرانيه من المحتمل بان
اوكرانيا ستواصل وتقدمها في ساحات المعارك
وتحالف القوات همم يقف في وجهه روسيا
اعتقد ان الحل الوحيد اللي انهاء هذه
الحرب
يتمثلوا في خساره روسيا لوجودها في
اوكرانيا
مساعد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
روسيا اوكرانيا واشنطن
فانا السفير اندرويد بكلانو نايبر رئيس
جمعيه الدبلوماسيه
الى هنا نصل لنهايه هذا الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر فيها
[موسيقى]